- You are pregnant. That's crazy cool.
- [Mandy] I'm pregnant.
- How excited are you?
- I am very excited.
- How did you break the
news to your family?
'Cause this is kind of a crap year, like,
you can't really be around everybody.
Did you get to be around
anybody and tell them?
- I, not really.
So my parents, we broke
the news, like, you know,
via Zoom, which was lovely,
but not the way that you sort
of had built up in your brain,
but my in-laws live very close to us
and it was my mother-in-law's
birthday, and we decided like,
this is the perfect birthday gift for her.
We're gonna, we're gonna
like give her a picture
of the ultrasound.
And so we gave her a
gift and we were like,
"Open your card at the end."
And the card just said,
"Happy birthday, Grandma."
And she read the card and
was like, "Oh, thanks."
Like a little insulted, I think,
that we were calling her "Grandma."
- (laughs)
- And then my husband took
a picture of the ultrasound
out of his pocket and like
tossed it down on the table.
And I never heard a human
being make the sound
that she made.
It was like a cry and a scream.
And exasperation, like,
it was, I was very worried
that she was gonna have a heart attack.
I'm like, "Kathy, you've got to breathe.
Like everything. It's good news.
It's happy news."
She was just so beside
herself with excitement.
- I love that she was
insulted because she was like,
"So you're old." (laughs)
That's my favorite part.